did you miss your chance to grab the
Final Fantasy 15 ultimate collector's
edition only 30,000 units were available
worldwide so you're not alone
fortunately Square Enix is looking into
manufacturing more silicon ara
translated game director Hajime Tabata
comments on the situation he said
pre-orders for the ultimate collector's
edition vanished in a flash and we've
received plenty of voices from those
that weren't able to acquire it at the
moment we're continuing with internal
coordination to see if we can somehow
increase its production we will make an
announcement as soon as there's any
progress Square is also aware of people
secondhand selling the ultimate
collector's edition at prices nearing
seven hundred dollars normally it costs
two hundred and seventy dollars and is
sold exclusively through squares online
store releasing more units will
hopefully help with the problem in any
case we'll all enjoy Final Fantasy 15
when it releases on sep tember 30th
until then stay tuned to gamespot for
all the latest on Final Fantasy